so yoga does that like I've never done
it I heard it's good for you though no
this man I've been I I've been doing
High yoga for like almost a year now you
love it I love it it's it's like it's
really a life hack you get very very
very uh very you know zinned you know
Mind Body Spirit you feel like healthier
doing it yeah you know because you know
all that [ __ ] like helps like your
insides and [ __ ] and you know like you
know in my in my profession like you
know we drink a lot of alcohol and of
course do a lot of crazy [ __ ] yeah but
like all that stuff like
um like activates certain things you're
stretching certain things and you're
you're you're like the insides like
really get that flow of like how they're
supposed to be like stretched out and
like moved around and the blood is like
transferring from your head to right
powering your feet and all that stuff is
like really it's like also like an
exercise like they're like really
burning calories and [ __ ] bro I'll be in
there like literally like sweating bro
like
like sweating does it get funky in those
things that look there's there's like
the like the bigger corporate spots like
where they're they're just like muelling
those spots are a little funky yeah you
gotta find you gotta find the little
like little Tucky like Mom and Pops
joints that are like independently or
just like kind of like smaller so it's
like you you don't get that like kind of
like cow mule kind of thing it's like
they're just like loading 30 people in a
room and then the next 30 people come
they're not cleaning it but usually like
the spots that I go to is just like they
go in there wipe like they make sure
everything wipe down they wipe down all
the weights and would you consider
yourself like a spiritual guy
uh yeah I would I would like to think so
I would like to think so religious
um I mean you know we've had our bouts
with Jesus Christ you know yeah I I
think I think you remember that
interview we did we were like Jesus
Christ Jesus yeah I mean I I was so
funny at some point yeah like I think uh
I know I yeah I would say a little bit
religious but like I know I'm more like
but I would more say more spiritual like
I feel like someone's up there learning
this whole thing right I feel like I
feel like most people probably feel that
way right where you're probably like I'm
not sure I'm gonna commit to any of
these man-made religions as much as like
trying to get right like with you know
yeah I yeah I don't think uh
uh I don't think God looks like the uh
the guy that they're like
putting out there so not like Morgan
Freeman
I mean he might look like Morgan Freeman
I'd be cool that'll be actually cool
yeah I'll I wouldn't be mad if I look
like Morgan Freeman and he had his voice
divorce would really say the voice would
set it off yeah that sets It Off